. Da ist aber jemand gut drauf heute. Ja, ich bin fantastisch drauf. Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey. Komm gararkastisch fang ich nicht an, Schaffee, ernsthaft. Oh, jetzt kommen deine ekelhaften Trinkgeräusche. Zieht er sich da ein stilles Wasser rein? Komm, fang an, die Scheisse ist hier. Was ist los mit dir, Stefan, du veränderst dich. Ich trinke schickes Wasser. Du hast gerade gefreestyle- Ey, ich trinke nicht immer stilles Wasser. Stefan, du hast hast gerade gefreestyle rappt, du hast Salz, Pfeffer, Pfeffer, Salz gerappt. Nein, ich habe Käse, Raser, Rack rappt. Rappen ist eine feine Linie zwischen Rappen und Schlaganfall. Du bist definitiv eher auf der Schlaganfallseite. Das ist kein Rappen. Können Sie bitte die Bühne verlassen? Will I be pretty, will I be rich? Das ist brandschutztechnisch ganz schwierig. Können Sie bitte die Flasche weglegen? Können Sie bitte von dem Mikrofon weggehen? Entschuldigen Sie, Herr Dietze, das ist eine Comedy-Show. Hier ist kein Publikum. Tut mir leid, können Sie bitte ... Ups. Wie lustig wäre es, wenn man vom stillen Wasser betrunken wird. Wenn manche Leute einfach vom stillen Wasser sehr laut werden. Ich liebe stilles Wasser. Wenn stilles Wasser den gleichen Effekt hätte wie sehr viel Alkohol. Wenn man einfach so eine grosse Wolve in der Hand hat. Und Leute, die eine grosse Wolve in der Hand hat, würden so Familien vorbeigehen, ach, da sind Assis wieder. Wie einfach so eine grosse, beim Arzt, wenn man in diesen Behältern steht, wo man Wasser sich raus macht und dann macht es ja. Dann hat man nur stilles Wasser, wo man sagen würde, ach, seht euch die an. Vor allem ist es so ein Konzept, dass diese Becher bei diesen Wasserspendern einfach nicht wasserdicht sind? Nee, ich glaube, die Idee ist, dass du nicht mehr trinkst. Es sei denn, du musst den neuen Becher nehmen dann. Weil ich sag mal so, wenn ich die Aufgabe bekomme, designe Becher für so einen Wasserspender, ist mein erster Gedanke, pass auf, die sollen wasserdicht sein. Und ich finde es interessant, dass sich ein Design durchgesetzt hat, das schlicht nicht wasserdicht ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass sich das Design durchgesetzt hat, sondern die Idee, dass man halt nur einmal daraus trinkt. Und dann muss man den Becher wegschmeissen. Du meinst, wie bei Super Mario diese Plattformen, auf die man springt, aber dann lösen die sich langsam auf und man muss schnell wieder weiterspringen. Genau, wie bei Super Mario. Du findest für alles die beste Super Mario-Analogie, oder? Ja.
Okay, herzlich willkommen zu Das Podcast-Ofo mit... Mit Stefan T. Und Florentin W. Herzlich willkommen und hallo in unserer neuen Sendung und heute sind wir bei 1, 2, 5, meine Damen und Herren. 1, 2, 5 FM. Das ist 8 durch 5, nee, 10 durch 8. Quersumme acht, wer nochmal eine Quersumme acht Folge hören will, der kann sich auf Folge dreiundfünfzig freuen, auf Folge fünfunddreißig und auf Folge acht und vierundvierzig. Und die vierundvierzig. Und heute, wir haben ein Achtel der tausend. Freust du dich auch schon so auf die Folge tausend wie ich? Wen haben wir in Folge tausend zu Gast? Noel Gallagher. Christopher Nolan. Und Nolan Gallagher. Weißt du noch, dass wir bei der ... Kurz direkt mal mit einem Insider, wo wir alle direkt mega unrelatable werden, dass wir bei der Einspielerschleife vom Neomagazin am Ende Christopher Nolan angefragt haben, damit er am Ende sagt, zu kompliziert. Zu kompliziert, ja. Hat nicht funktioniert. Hat nicht funktioniert! Aber Christopher Nolan, Noon Gallagher und Gallagher irgendwas. Und dann macht man einen so im grossen Kreis von zehn Leuten. John Gallagher Junior gibt's noch, Junior, den von Newsroom und 10 Cloverfield Lane. Ich hab Ahnung von Filmen. James Cameron, Cameron Diaz. Diaz ... Diaz Gonzales. Diaz Gonzales Inarito. Die berühmte Soap-Schauspielerin. Wir lieben mexikanische Soaps. Man hat halt so Kettenleute, die halt versuchen, die Kette ... Und die gehen dann wieder um in, keine Ahnung, Diaz Leiser, und dann kannst du halt Leiser Minnelli, Kylie Minnelli-Logue, Logan Paul, Paul, Dano, Dano, Smudo, herzlich willkommen, hier ist Smudo. Hey, Dano Smudo, nee. Aber das ist ja auch so ein berühmtes Spiel in Foren, wenn man in Foren, gibt es ja immer in diesen lustigen Ecken, gibt es dann immer Spiele, Dieser Wort, wo man halt ein zusammengesetztes Wort nehmen muss, und der andere muss ein Wort finden, was mit dem Wort anfängt, womit der andere aufgehört hat. Ich war noch nie, also das sind für mich wirklich die absoluten Versager, die in einem Forum sind, das sich fachspezifisch orientiert und die dann noch sagen, nee, ich will nicht über Karpfen reden in diesem Karpfenforum, sondern ich will einfach so mit den Leuten chatten, in der Albern. Spiele-Ecke, in der Off-Topic-Ecke. Der Quasit-Thread. Vor allem, du bist einen Klick entfernt von einem cooleren Quasit-Thread oder einem cooleren Spiel. Oder du redest mit einer Frau, die drei Meter neben dir liegt. Tot, weil du die Woche lang nicht mehr geguckt hast, ob sie noch lebt. Das stimmt, das muss man ja ab und zu machen, ja. Oh Mann, eins, zwei, fünf, heute das Thema. Quer Nummer acht hatten wir schon. Weißt du, was mir neulich klar aufgefallen ist? Wir sind ein UFO. Wir können, wenn wir wollen, einfach zum nächsten Thema fliegen. Das stimmt. Das machen wir viel zu selten. Total, wir bleiben immer so irgendwie, weil wir die Folge füllen wollen, so wie Star Trek. Wir bleiben viel zu lange auf einem Planeten, wo man sagt, ich hab's verstanden. Ich glaube, Star Trek nicht ist, wo wir viel zu lange an einem Ort zu sein. Die Leute hier reden durch die Nase und hören durch die Stirn, ich hab's gecheckt, aber alle so, oh nein, wir müssen da die Prämisse noch weiter auskleiden und so. Nervt mich persönlich. Fahr zum nächsten Planeten, genau, schmeiß die Motoren an und flieg zum nächsten Thema, flieg zum nächsten Planeten. Das können wir auch machen. Wohin willst du? Volle Kraft voraus in Richtung Ausstieg in Fahrtrichtung? Hawaii. Stefan will nach Hawaii.
Wollen wir nach Hawaii fliegen?
Hast du das vor diesem Raketentest mitbekommen?
Nein.
Ich habe jetzt gerade Hawaii tatsächlich einfach nur so gesagt, aber da ist ja wirklich was passiert.
Kurz, wir haben auch eine neue Rubrik, wo wir zu spät über Themen reden, die irgendwann mal aktuell waren.
Ja.
Late to the party.
Topical Island, topical party.
Ja, aber da gab es ja diesen Test, der kein Test war. Also da kam es dann zu dem, hast du mitbekommen? Es wurde gesagt, Achtung, gleich schlägt dir ein nukleärer Sprengsatz ein, bei uns, ein Sprengkörper, bitte, das ist keine Übung, bitte, wir wissen auch nicht genau, was sie tun sollen, sie werden eh alle sterben. Und dann stand überall, this is not a drill, this is not a drill, alle haben das Smartphone bekommen. Genau, dann wollte der Präsident von, oder der Vorsitzende, der Bürgermeister von Hawaii halt, der wollte halt sagen, das ist irgendwie gerade ein Fehler, diese Meldung wurde versehentlich rausgeschickt, aber sein Handy war leer, deswegen konnte er es auch nicht twittern, niemand konnte es mehr twittern. Er wurde laut gerufen. Und dann nach einer halben Stunde wurde gesagt, oh sorry, es war nur ein Test, aber alle Hawaiianer und Urlauber, die da waren, waren sich für eine halbe Stunde sicher, dass sie gleich sterben werden. Hast du es nicht mitbekommen? Mega. Aber was macht man in der Zeit? Also du kannst ja nichts machen. Viele sind in den Keller gegangen. Ja, viel Erfolg. Das finde ich bei dem Simpsons-Film so toll, wo die Armageddon steht bevor und die aus der Kirche gehen in die Bar und die aus der Bar gehen in die Kirche. Toll. Wahnsinn, oder? Die sind total clever. Das ist ein feiner Humor. Witty. Ganz feiner Humor. Nee, das fand ich total lustig. Und überall stand auch explizit, this is not a drill. Auch Ausrufezeichen, Ausrufezeichen, Ausru Ausrufezeichen, was doof ist, wenn es ein Drill ist. Ne, hab ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Ich dachte jetzt, dieser SpaceX-Ding von Elon Musk. Henry Maske, Maski, Maskenata, Maskenata, Maskenata, Maskenata, ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, jede Woche fällt er mir ein. Five days, once in a lifetime, five nights... Gema. Achtung! Gema, living on a Gema. Ich versuche einfach nur, möglichst viele Orbe-Mauder zu bringen. Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da Sie eingeschickt haben, haben uns sehr gut gefallen. Wir suchen nach dem tollen Agenten, einem tollen Agenten-Theme und einfach eine spannende Musik. Und ja, wir freuen uns auf das, was Sie mitgebracht haben. Genau. Stellen Sie einfach vor. Also für mich natürlich im Vordergrund steht natürlich beim Agent die Geheimhaltung. Es ist eine Geheimhaltung. Wir haben ja auch in dem Plot angelegt diese zwei Identitäten des Charakters. Und ich habe einfach versucht, das so ein bisschen in der Musik darzustellen. Es ist eine Heimlichkeit, es ist eine Heimlichkeit, die spannungsgeladen ist. Also es ist eine Heimlichkeit, die auf etwas hinzieht. Deswegen, also es ist jetzt noch relativ roh. Ja, kein Problem. Ich kann es dir jetzt einfach mal vorstellen. Wurden Sie einfach mal vorstellen. Also wir haben am Anfang natürlich so ein bisschen, auch um in die Szene reinzugehen, haben wir dieses Wow, wow. So, einfach um schon mal das Setting. Man kann es sich genau vorstellen, da schleicht jemand irgendwie um die Ecke. Vielleicht so diese Special Gadgets, die Sie ja betont haben, die Ihnen wichtig sind irgendwie. Ja, wir sind aber nicht zu sehr James Bond, wir sind auch nicht James Bourne, wir sind auch nicht John Wick. Wir sind halt... Was war Mission Impossible noch? Hunt, Ethan Hunt. Ethan Hunt? Der kann, also der hat im Prinzip die Fähigkeiten von James Bond, Jason Bourne, aber er ist halt noch ein bisschen anders.
Die Figur ist vielleicht nicht so super, aber die Musik ist geil.
Die Musik ist geil.
Und ich dachte, jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie geht man da weiter.
Und ich kann mir ein bisschen fortspielen, wie es weitergeht. Dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum Simpel von den Akkorn. Mega gut. Richtig. Danke. Nächster. Okay. Ist auch visuell der Gag teilweise, weil man dann erschreckt die ganze Zeit. Natürlich. Bei jedem Dalle muss man halt auch zusammenzucken, die Leute sich vorstellen. Aber es ist aus dem Alltag gegriffen, es ist Comedy von Relatable. Also Leute wollten von uns, ey, ohne Scheiss, man kann ja mal sagen, wir haben vor, die grosse, gute Arbeit Original, das Podcast-Sufufel-Folge zu machen, eine grosse Crossover, um einfach bei das Ende zu sprechen, um die dirty Details hinter den Kulissen zu erzählen. Alles klar. Okay. hey! Hey! Rumpelteam! Hey, wach auf jetzt! Oh, danke. Ey, du hast mir gerade das Leben gerettet. Du hast mir zweimal kräftig gegen den Oberarm geschlagen. Du hast mir das Leben gerettet, Alter. Ich habe zwei blaue Flecke wegen dir. Ich glaube, du hast mir das Leben gerettet. Alter, danke schön. Ja, gern. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das wieder gut machen kann. Ey, du musst echt aufpassen. Ey, du hast gesagt, Hilfe, fuck, was soll ich machen, Hilfe, Hilfe, und hast mir zweimal gegen den Arm geschlagen. Und dann ging's wieder. Und 1-1-3 gewählt. Aus Versehen. Man weiß nicht warum. Fühlst du dich sicher? Nein. Gegenwart ist beim Ernst, fühlst du dich sicher? Nee. Glaubst du, ich könnte in der Katastrophe mich um dich kümmern, um dich sorgen, dich verteidigen? Nee. Ich muss nicht lange drüber nachdenken. Fühlst du dich sicher? Ich hab mal eine Erste-Hilfe-Kurs. Erst mal müsste man sich eigentlich mit jedem sicher fühlen, weil man alle, die über achtzehn sind, einen Führerschein haben, haben mal einen Erste-Hilfe-Kurs gemacht. Natürlich. Wow! Eigentlich müsstest du die Ahnung haben, aber ich fühl mich nicht sicher neben dir. Weil du mit Sicherheit nicht ... Also ich habe zumindest, weiß ich, dass man Staying Alive summen muss, während der Herzrhythmusmassage, weil es lustig ist und glaube ich, weil die BPM-Anzahl mit dem Herzschlag übereinstimmt. Ich glaube, das Wichtigste ist, dass du einfach sobald jemanden die Hand abgehackt bekommt, einfach Staying Alive singen, einfach komplett durch den ganzen Prozess, auch während dem Anruf beim Notruf, einfach um alle Leute so ein bisschen zu beruhigen, was ich nämlich weiß,
bei Amputation
nicht einfach in Eiswasser
schmeißen, den Fehler machen ganz viele.
Eis, Eis, Baby.
Genau, das ist der Song.
Das ist der Song für Amputation.
Das ist wichtig.
Ich habe euch eine Playlist zusammengestellt.
Spotify 1 und 2
Playlist. Eis, Eis, Baby, Stayingestellt. Spotify 1 und 2 Playlist.
Eis Eis Baby, Staying Alive. Ja. Und Born to be Alive. Ganz wichtig, nicht einfach in Eiswasser werfen, den abgetrennten Finger, sondern in einen Beutel und den Beutel in Eiswasser, aber auch nicht nur in Eis, sondern in Eiswasser, weil Eis an sich ist zu kalt, der wird dem Finger kalt. und dann kann man den nicht mehr amputieren, deportieren, was sagt man?
Amputieren.
Reportieren?
Nee, wenn man ihn dann wieder ranschweißt. Amputieren. Ne, dranputieren. Dranputieren. Bin mir nicht sicher. Dranlöten. Das ist echt ein Problem. Mir wurde halt andauernd, also es wird halt in diesen Erste-Hilfe-Kurs, erstmal war unser Erste-Hilfe-Kurs ein bisschen strange, ich musste auch in die Nachbarstadt fahren und so, dann war das irgendwie so ein Keller und man hat sich gefragt, ist hier der Erste-Hilfe-Kurs und dann hat so eine besoffene Frau irgendwie im Flur gesagt, dann muss ich runtergehen, dann bin ich runtergegangen und dann war unten in der Erste-Hilfe-Kurs in so einem Kellerartigen Gewölbe und dann weiß ich noch, da waren sehr viele Schüler auch und einer ging es schlecht die ganze Zeit. Es gibt immer, das hat man häufig. This is not a drill. Gehörte sie zum Teil? Dachte ich auch. Ist sie Teil des Programms hier? Nee, sie war einfach eine Besucherin, der uns da schlecht ging. Und dann musste sie sich erbrechen auch, als wir draußen waren. Und dann hat man sich, dann hat er erst Helfer. Hat er Panik. Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, was macht man jetzt?
Stay alive, stay alive, dum, dum, dum, dum, fuck!
Ich kenn's nur der Theorie, was macht man jetzt?
Dann hat er uns an ihr erklärt, was man macht,
wenn jemand Kreislaufprobleme hat, um die man sich erbricht.
Nämlich Schokoriegel geben, Glas Wasser geben.
Und ich weiß, was man macht, wenn's einem schlecht geht
im Erste-Lüfe-Kurs, ich weiß nicht, was man macht, wenn man den Kopf verliert oder einen Arm verliert.
Erstmal Schokoriegel geben, ich glaube, das ist auch bei Unfallopfern erstmal gut, erstmal ein Snickers, da hat noch nie geschadet. Einfach mal Kreislauf wieder auf Vordergrund. Ja, und mir wird häufig, das habe ich in Erinnerung, es wird häufig gesagt, einfach Ruhe behalten, einfach Ruhe behalten.
Chill out.
Es wurde mir so häufig gesagt, dass ich einfach erstmal die Ruhe bewahren muss, dass ich mich einfach wahrscheinlich beim Unfall erstmal hinlege. Erstmal hinlege. Erstmal WhatsApp aufmachen. Erstmal Ruhe bewahren. Die haben lustige Sticker, erstmal da ein bisschen was swipen, runterkommen. Notfallfreizeichen, Ruhe bewahren. Erstmal runterkommen runterkommen, Mann, Mensch, Mann, nicht, Mann. Komm mal runter, aah! Komm mal runter, entspannen. Muss mein Kopf brennen, muss mein Kopf in Flammen sein! Max, Alter, ich hab eine Playlist, ein bisschen Reggae, einfach mach's ein bisschen an, ein bisschen runterkommen, alles okay, überhaupt kein Problem. Ein bisschen Reggae, ich hab einen von den beiden Reggae-Songs angemacht. Das stimmt. Gibt's ja das Video, habe ich gestern gesehen, wo Uma Thurman, Uma, Uma, Uma Thurman, komischer, Uma Thurman hat einen Unfall gehabt, weil Quentin Tarantino beim Dreh von Kill Bill sie dazu gezwungen hat, in einem Wagen zu fahren. Genau, also kein Stuntdouble? Bei dir hat ja Death Proof gedreht. Nicht überlebt. Nee, das Stuntdouble von Yuma Thurman in Kilbel ist ja in Death Proof. Deswegen konnte die es nicht machen, weil die eigene Film gedreht hat. Weil die zu gut wurde als Stuntdouble. Deswegen sollte man Stuntdouble nie gut genug werden. Auf keinen Fall. Und dann haben die gesagt, Yuma, mach das mal bitte selber jetzt, fahr bitte selber den Wagen. Sie hat sich aber schon beschwert, weil der Wagen war wohl nicht ganz in Ordnung, aber im Nachhinein war wohl doch in Ordnung. Und dann hat sie einen Unfall gebaut dann tatsächlich. Und da habe ich unter dem Video gelesen, das ist auch ganz, das ist nicht so toll anzusehen. Und dann hat der Ersthelfer vor Ort auch nicht richtig gehandelt. Da stand drunter, man soll nicht den Kopf anfassen. Also Schokoriegel ins Maul drücken, aber dabei nicht den Kopf verrücken,
weil das Genick kann gebrochen sein.
Und natürlich immer das Katana entfernen, auch das ist ganz wichtig.
Das was? Das Katana, das ist,
so nennt man ein, das Schwert
der Samurai, das verwendet wurde, zum Beispiel in Kill Bill,
in vielen Szenen.
katana-forum.de, schaut mal vorbei,
irgendwie, ich hab noch nicht so viele User. Und schaut mal bei Ebay, der Power-Seller für Katana-Forum.de, schaut mal vorbei, irgendwie, ich hab noch nicht so viele User.
Und schaut mal bei Ebay, der Power-Seller für Katana. Ja, übrigens vielen Dank an den User, der den Filmfehler-Forum-Eintrag gefunden hat, von Florentin, das fand ich ganz toll. Da kann man auch gucken, was Florentin noch so geschrieben hat, habe ich aber, das hätte ich noch nicht gemacht. Es ist immer schön zu sehen, dass wenn man auch mal den Vorhang des Showbusiness lupft und einen kleinen Einblick in die Privatrieben hat. Habe ich aber, das hätte ich noch nicht gemacht. Es ist immer schön zu sehen, dass wenn man, sag ich mal, auch mal
den kleinen, den Vorhang des Showbusiness lupft und einen kleinen Einblick in die Privatsphäre, dass die Leute sofort aufreißen und
gnadenlos alles runterziehen. Die Leute laufen auf die Bühne und halten den Vorhang hoch und gucken rein, was da noch so ist.
Wow, der gibt eine Schwäche zu, dann bohren wir doch genau da rein, weil wir mögen, was der macht. Das ist doch genau das Richtige.
Naja, kann man nicht sagen.
Dafür habe ich in letzter Folge gesagt, am Ende, dass man bitte nicht in Aktien investieren sollte mehr.
Und danach hat jemand geschrieben, danach ist der Dow Jones massiv eingebrochen auf so ein Allzeittief.
Holy shit.
Nicht schlecht.
Ja.
Aber so funktionieren Aktien ja auch, wenn jetzt alle sagen, na, nee?
Es ist ja schon so ein Gefühlsding, es ist ja schon so ein Meinungsding, aber wir wissen es nicht.
Wir wissen es doch nicht, es ist Klima, es ist so ein bisschen, ja, VW, fühlt sich gerade nicht so richtig an, Arktik geht in den Keller.
Willst du mal ein Thema fliegen?
Oh ja.
Okay, wohin willst du fliegen?
Stephans Privatleben.
Come on!
Ich verliere so ein bisschen den Kontakt zu dir. Was ist los bei dir, was treibst du so? Du schickst mir nur noch Gifs auf Telegram, irgendwie, unsere Kommunikation, wo du nur noch von Gags und Memes ersetzt. Und ich kenne dich nur noch als Meme-Lord Stefan, aber gar nicht mehr, was dahintersteckt. Was ist der Mensch, der dahintersteckt? Vor allem, du hast heute wieder getwittert. Du hast heute wieder schön Gags rausgeräumt bei Twitter. Ganz toll. Ich bin jetzt wieder auf dem Markt, ich habe mich jetzt erholt nach dem Comedy-Trauma, das Folge 118 war. Und seitdem bin ich wieder an Bord. Ich habe noch ein anderes Projekt. Anders als du habe ich noch einen Job. Ach cool. Ja, bin gut untergekommen, cooler Job, cooles Projekt, schön, ein bisschen was anderes. Nicht mal diese Comedy-Scheisse, auch ein bisschen seriös arbeiten. Aber das Schlimme ist, dass irgendwann Leuten auffällt, dass man das nicht kann. Das ist ein Problem. Du bist jetzt bei dieser Versicherung, ne? Ja, ja, ja. Und wie läuft das? Ist das da? Ne, ist gut. Also ich habe den Bereich M bis L. Okay. Und ja, ich sage mal so, also da ist eigentlich nur gerade Familie Müller, aber das ändern wir. Also da arbeiten wir daran, dass es ein bisschen mehr werden vielleicht. Und ja, also wir geben verschiedene Angebote, zum Beispiel Erdbebenversicherung, Tsunamiversicherung, genau. Und da muss man halt Leute anrufen und sagen, hey, wollen Sie das? Die meisten Leute legen schimpfend auf. Ja, und das ist halt mein Job. Ist halt schon anstrengend so, aber ich sag mal, die Bezahlung ist okay. Und die Mittagspause gibt eine Kantine, hatten wir sonst nicht. Das ist cool. Also man hat, man kommt gut, ich komme gut durch. Hast du schon bei so Amazon-Sachen eine Versicherung abgeschlossen? Nee. Weil wenn man das bestellt, kann man manchmal irgendwie so, ich glaube, das orientiert sich einfach am Preis. Man kauft sich einen Mixer für 50 Euro und dann sagen sie, können sie für 1,50 Euro eine Versicherung. Das ist statt zwei Jahren Garantie 20 Jahre Garantie. Man ist geneigt, draufzuklicken, weil das so billig ist. Das ist so abstrakt, was das jetzt bedeutet. Ich habe in meinem Leben noch nie irgendwas zurückgeschickt oder irgendeine Versicherung eingefordert, irgendwie sowas. Deswegen mache ich das nicht. Nee, es ist schon interessant. Vor allem ist es auch interessant, dass man je nach Browser mehr bezahlen muss. Also wenn ich mit einem Mac auf Amazon gehe, mit Safari, sind die Preise höher häufig. Kleiner Tipp an unsere Sparfüchse da draußen, einen kleinen Lifehack, den ich letztens zugesteckt habe. Ja, wenn du mit einem alten Röhrenbildschirm reingehen, dann bezahlst du nichts. Und zwar, Amazon setzt automatisch Produkte runter, die du in deinem Warenkorb hast, aber nicht kaufst. Also alle den Lamborghini. Lamborghini, schön für 2,5 Millionen in den Warenkorb. Bis er noch 10 Euro kostet.
Und zufällig bekommt man eine Woche später, oh, der wurde runtergesetzt von 2,5 auf 2,49999 Millionen und du, jetzt aber. Und man kann die anrufen, wenn man gesehen hat, dass der Preis sich vom Kauf bis zum Verschicken noch geändert hat, billiger geworden ist. Kann man denen schreiben, dann sagen die, wie heißt wie heißt der was? Ja, scheiß drauf. Wir haben so viel Geld, Alter, komm mal, weißt du, hier hast du noch einen Zehner oben drauf und einen Einkaufsgutschein oben drauf. Übrigens, du hast massive Kritik geerntet für deinen Briefbetrugs-Scan, den du vorgestellt hast. Manche haben gesagt, es funktioniert, manche haben gesagt, es funktioniert nicht. Es ist so ein halbes Loophole, es ist so ein bisschen, man weiß nicht genau. In der Theorie ist es geil, in der Praxis ist es zu 50 Prozent geil.
Einer hat den Brief wieder selber zurückbekommen, wo ich mir denke, ich glaube, du hast die Adresse falsch aufgeschrieben, weil, also wenn du den Brief selber zurückbekommen hast. Steffans Betrug war, dass man als Absender die eigentliche Adresse auf den Brief schreibt und als eigentliche Adresse irgendwie Mordor, kann man da einen kleinen Gag machen. Und dann, wenn der Brief nicht zustellbar ist, wird er automatisch zum Absender zurückgeschickt, der aber eigentlich der echte Adressat ist, der dann sagt zu so mal, glauben Sie, wir machen seit 200 Jahren Post und noch nie hat jemand diesen Scheiß-Gag rausbekommen? Sie zahlen jetzt mal schön. Und dann stehst du da und ich weiß gar nicht, von wem der Brief ist. Apropos Post, wir müssen aber das große Thema Nachbarn nehmen Pakete ansprechen. Ich weiss nicht, du hast es häufiger erlebt, bei mir ist es ganz schlimm, weil ich nie zu Hause bin einfach. Gut, du bist jetzt häufiger zu Hause, also auffällig häufig zu Hause, aber ich bin nicht so oft zu Hause. Und deswegen landen bei dem Brief immer bei Nachbarn und so ein Kram. Und man sollte als Nachbar, da gibt es ein paar Unwritten Laws, ein paar ungeschriebene Gesetze der Gesellschaft, die man einhalten sollte. Ja, Punkt eins, die Tür nicht aufmachen. Ich bin nicht zu Hause. Ist Regel Nummer eins. Die Tür klingelt und ich habe nicht vor einer Stunde etwas zu essen bestellt. Ich bin nicht zu Hause. Mein Licht ist an, die Dusche läuft, Musik läuft, ich bin nicht zu Hause. Das ist Regel Nummer eins. Genau, offensichtlich ist niemand da. Aber ich habe gestern, das ist Regel Nummer zwei, ich habe gestern, mein Nachbar habe ich einen Brief von Amazon bekommen und er hat gesagt, er hat es genommen, hat gesagt, ah, das ist aber sehr klein. Dann hast du mir gegeben. Und dann hat er gesagt, okay. Dann hat er mir, kommentiere nicht, was ich bekomme. Das ist auch ein bisschen so eine Diskretionssache. Jetzt habe ich das ausgepackt, hast du reingeguckt? Vor allem, warum kommentierst du das, was ich bestelle? Das hat ja nichts zu tun. Das ist auch so ein Ding. Das ist schrecklich. Ich habe aber jetzt auch das Beste herausgefunden, es gibt und zwar Parkstationen. Ich habe endlich die Parkstationen. Und es ist so geil, weil du fühlst dich wie in so einer 90er-Jahre-Kids-Show, wo du vor dieser großen Wand stehst, mit ganz vielen Fächern und du tippst dann... Und wenn du die richtige Zahl einst. Ja, denn vor allem, also Packstation ist, dass man sich nicht nach Hause irgendwas bestellt, sondern zu einer Packstation und das ist einfach... Was meistens für Drogen benutzt wird. Und das ist ein großer Roboter, wo einfach ganz viele Klappen sind und wo das Paket in eine Klappe kommt und du hast den Code für die richtige Klappe und es ist wirklich so wie bei Tabaluga-TV, dass du dich erstmal durch so eine U-Bahn kämpfen musst und da auf die Fliesen steigen musst, die nicht voller Kotze sind. Du bist im Tabaluga-Fieber. Und dann kommst du an diesem Terminal an. Du musst Snake spielen. Du musst Snake spielen, du kommst am Terminal an und kriegst dann auch noch von Ed Tabaluga den geheimen Code auf dein Handy. Und dann tippst du den ein und dann ist der allergeilste Moment der Packstation, du weisst nicht, welche Klappe aufgeht. Du stehst vor dieser riesigen Wand Klappen und wirklich wie in so einem Film, wo geht eine Klappe auf, so klonk. Und plötzlich, du weißt genau, Crash, Zoom auf diese Klappe und du weißt genau, geil, da muss ich hin. Und das ist so cool, weil du weißt nicht, wo es ist und es ist so ein bisschen Geheimagenten-mäßig, so jemand hat für dich ein Päckchen abgeliefert und du gehst dahin und in diesem Moment dieses Bip, Bip, Bip, Bip, Klack. Du weißt, ihn ist rechts, links, oben und so cool. Ist richtig cool einfach. Und dann kommt jemand angelaufen und Obdachloser nimmt dein Paket raus und rennt weg. Und dann kannst du nichts mehr machen. Du kannst tatsächlich auch von da und das ist ein Mind-on-Life-Act, du kannst von da auch Pakete verschicken. Du musst nicht zur Boss gehen mehr. Anstehen, forget it! Schön einfach, weil da ist so ein Barcode-Ding, hältst du dein Paket dran, dann macht's piep, dann geht eine Klappe irgendwo auf und legst es da rein. Wo hast du den Barcode her? Der ist auf dem Paket drauf. Aber du verschickst es doch selbst. Wo kriegst du denn den Barcode her? Wenn du auf Retour klickst bei Amazon, kriegst du einen Barcode. Ach so, und dann musst du ausdrucken, oder was? Ja. Stimmt, du musstest dann eigentlich auch noch zu Post geben. Dann musst du das Paket in den Drucker stecken. Ja. Das ist ja Quatsch. Wo willst du aus? Vom Podcast-Sufo getestet. Ich bin mittlerweile auch so, ich schätze, welche Klappe ist es. Und ich sag mal so, von zwei Klappen lage ich zweimal falsch. Aber ich werde besser. Ich denke mir, na wo ist es? Wie groß ist die Chance so? Relativ niedrig. Relativ niedrig, ne? Ja. So ein bisschen wie dieses, ich weiß nicht, ob du schon mal bei der Bundeswehr warst, aber ich war auf der Gamescom am Stand der Bundeswehr und ich dachte mir so, ich will Supersoldat werden. Und anscheinend, wofür die Bundeswehr primär zuständig ist, ist eine große leuchtende Wand zu installieren mit ganz vielen Buttons. Und sobald ein Button aufleuchtet, musst du draufdotsen. Und dann stehe ich davor, schweißgebadet mit einem Slush in der linken Hand, irgendwie. Hast alle Punkte getroffen und dann, ISIS ist jetzt tot.
ISIS ist jetzt tot, du hast genug Reaktionen gehabt.
Und dann dotzt man da so drauf rum und denkt sich,
gut, bereite mich das auf Afghanistan vor.
Stimmt, du bist sehr gut, dann gibt es auch immer diese Rekordlisten und wenn du sehr gut
den Tagesrekord brichst und so, dann irgendwer
so ein Officer neben dir steht, plötzlich,
verdammt, der war echt gut, den können wir echt bei uns gebrauchen.
Komm, dann
sprechen sie dich an und dann werden die sich an.
Ja, und du kriegst direkt so den Orden.
Du bist direkt General.
Also das ist immer toll, aber da, das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an diese Packstationen-Ding, dass du so ganz viele Klappen hast.
Ja, hab ich ausgedacht.
Und du musst sofort da sein. Sobald die Klappe aufgeht, musst du da sein.
Ja.
Wir finden es nicht schlecht, das ist eine gute Sache.
Packstationen, da gibt es aber nicht so viele leider. Es gibt nicht so viele Packstationen.
Es gibt große und dann gibt es auch die kleinen. Es gibt so ein bisschen die Independent-Pstationen, die auch teilweise so auf Innenhöfen von irgendwie so Forschungsinstituten, man lernt die Stadt kennen. So kleine Sachen. Stimmt, bei Unis und Schulen häufig. Und es ist teilweise so ein bisschen wie so ein Fantasy-Roman, so das Heilige Schwert wurde in vier Teile zerbrochen, überall über das Königreich verstreut, Reich verstreut. Und so ist es auch so, du bestellst drei Dosen
Jalapenos und jede
Dose kommt an eine andere Packstation und dann musst du
ja sich auf die Quest machen. Du musst
losziehen in die weite Welt mit einem
Holzschwert und dann kämpfst du gegen irgendwelche Leute
und dann musst du irgendwie in Dungeon runter und du musst
alle drei Sachen sammeln. Das ist die reale Welt, ja.
Und am Ende hast du drei Dosen Jalapenos und denkst dir,
geil, das war richtig teuer.
Manchmal ist die Welt wie so ein
Online-Rollenspiel,
finde ich. Du kriegst dann immer, wenn du eine Sache
Vielen Dank. Da hast du drei Dosen Jalapenos und denkst dir, geil, das war richtig teuer. Manchmal ist die Welt wie so ein Online-Rollenspiel, finde ich. Du kriegst dann immer, wenn du eine Sache willst, heute habe ich zum Beispiel, bei der Website wollte ich was eröffnen und dann musste ich meinen Personalausweis haben. Dann ist der Personalausweis, den habe ich woanders vergessen, musste ich da hinfahren, den holen, dann habe ich den gehabt. Sidequest.. Sidequest, dann habe ich den gehabt, dann war der abgelaufen.
Jetzt muss ich zum Amt gehen und mir einen Personalausweis holen.
Oder du zahlst Geld, DLC.
Bitte?
Oder du kaufst dir den, im Onlineshop sozusagen.
Den Personalausweis?
Ja.
Kann man sich einen Personalausweis kaufen?
Ich meine, das ist in der Videospielmetapher.
Ach so.
Mach gerne weiter.
Ich meine, außer als, ich darf mittlerweile nicht mehr so viel über mein bürokratisches Privatleben sagen, weil mich immer mehr Nachrichten ereilen, so, hey, du musst dich wirklich um deine Steuern kümmern, hey, du musst dich wirklich um deine Versicherung kümmern, so, also meine Mutter wird abgelöst durch alle, so, also vorher hatte ich eine Mutter, jetzt habe ich potenziell sieben Milliarden Mütter, die alle schreiben, so, hey, du musst noch das zu Post bringen und so. Vielen Dank, Leute, dass ihr euch mich kümmert, aber ich kriege das schon alleine nicht hin, okay? Also macht euch keine Sorgen, das läuft schon, macht euch keine Sorgen. Ich habe auch mittlerweile so einen Anwalt neben und sitzt da die ganze Zeit mit dem Kopf schüttelt. Ja, ja, klar. Die ganze Zeit diese Geste, diese Kopfabgeste macht. Ja, ja. Was, halt einfach die Fresse. So, als ob man sich am Hals kratzen will. So seitlich, so. Man weiß es nicht genau. Warum sollen wir uns am Hals? Wie so ein Hund. Die können sich massiv schnell am Hals kratzen. Hunde und Katzen, nehmen manchmal diese ganz schnelle Pfote an Backe, wo man sich fragt, ist das denn effizienter, was wollen die damit erreichen? Weil wenn sie sich kratzen wollen, ist es nicht effizienter einfach nur kurz oder haben die Katzen so scharfe Krallen, dass es besser ist, wenn die so spitz sind, dass sie den Fleck gar nicht erreichen? Die haben halt im Verhältnis zum Körper so lange Gliedmassen, die sich nicht so gut biegen lassen. Also holen sie aus, Schwung meinst du? Naja, und die müssen halt, das ist so wie wenn du mit einer einen Meter langen Gabel essen müsstest. So, verstehst du? Dann musst du immer so ganz weit, weit rum nöseln, so, und dann hast du halt so ein Ding. Aber ich könnte mir nicht vorstellen, ein Tier zu sein, das ich nicht an jeder Körperstelle kratzen kann. Du kannst nicht an jeder Körperstelle kratzen. Du kannst dich nicht rein. Hinten im Schulterblatt kannst du dich nicht kratzen. Klar. Okay, zeig mir jetzt, wie du dich am Schulterblatt krass. So, so von hinten. Du kommst an Stellen nicht. An alles, wo ich oben nicht hinkomme ... Da gibt's ja einen Rückenkratzer. Challenge, ich komme an jede Körperstelle komme ich hin. Gib mir ein Edding und ich male mich einmal komplett an. Nicht in schwarz, das wäre rassistisch, aber ich male mich an. In blau. So, da male ich mich an. Schlumpf! Ja, ist nicht die Schauspielerin in dem James-Bond-Film, die sich ganz golden angemalt hat, gestorben, weil sie sich ganz golden angemalt hat? Ist das ein Urban Myth? Ist das ein Urban Myth, ja. Ja, wirklich? Ja. Ich meine, die ist gestorben, weil eine Stelle am Körper nicht mehr atmen konnte. Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, was, der Mund vielleicht? Man weiß es nicht genau. Und dann hat Wikipedia direkt geschrieben, nein, nicht der Mund, ach, steuft's. Nee, weil die Haut atmet ja auch. Und die eine Stelle am Rücken, wenn die bemalt wird, ist man sofort tot, offensichtlich. Aber zum Thema ein Meter lange Gabel, es gibt ja diese tolle Metapher. Wer mit dem grossen Löffel ist, der hat gewonnen. Ja, also wie man sich die Hölle vorstellt. In der Hölle essen alle mit Stäbchen, mit zwei Meter langen Stäbchen. Und sie haben so viel Mühe, Sachen sich in den Mund zu stecken, dass sie langsam und qualvoll verhungern. Und im Himmel haben auch alle zwei Meter lange Stäbchen, aber sie füttern sich gegenseitig. Was sagt man? Und ich dachte mir, wow, das ist ziemlich rassistisch, dass die Leute in der Hölle Stäbchen haben, um zu essen. Warum haben die nicht lange Gabeln? Warum sagt man nicht einfach, warum muss man diese Stäbchen dazu bauen? Vor allem, genau, weil Messer und Gabeln zwei Meter lang sind, ist auch nicht so mega gut. Und dann noch, warum haben die im Himmel, also wenn der Himmel so gut ist, warum haben die diese zwei Meter Stäbchen-Situation nicht verbessert? Das ist eine Metapher. Und vor allem, man kann die Stäbchen auch, man muss die ja nicht ganz am Ende anfassen. Man kann die ja auch wie so eine Feder, wo man dann oben noch so hin und her wackelt. Vor allem, nur weil die so lang sind, heißt das nicht, dass ihr die benutzen müsst. Man kann auch mit den Händen essen. Und in der Regel den Händen essen. Und in der Regel sind bei so Take-away-Sachen, kannst du da auch aus der Box direkt essen oder isst du eine Gabel dabei? Wenn ich in der Hölle wäre, würde ich erst sagen, fuck, wenn ich dann zu diesem Essraum gehen würde, wo alle mit diesen grossen Stäbchen da rumhandeln würden, würde ich nicht sagen, shit, das ist die Hölle. Ich würde sagen, geil, hier gibt es was zu essen. Das einzige Problem hier sind die zwei mittelangen Stäbchen. Leute, Mikado, ein grosses Mega-Mikado. Ich hab's auch ein bisschen erwartet, dass hier ein paar Dinge nicht so geil sind. Also wenn du schon in die Hölle kommst... Wenn es nur die Stäbchen sind, gut, ist ein Win für uns. Ich glaube, du hast nirgendwo eine bessere Erwartungshaltung als in der Hölle. Wenn jemand sagt, du bist in der Hölle, okay, ich erwarte das Schlimmste. Ich bin auf alles vorbereitet und dann sagt jemand, okay, du musst dir den ganzen Tag Hitler angucken, wie er mit zwei grossen Stäbchen ist. Geil! Geil! Mega cool! Goebbels, der mit seinem lustigen Bart dann irgendwie versucht, sich schön reinzudrücken. Lächerlich! Lächerlich! Die Nürnberger Prozesse? Ich gucke mal, glaube ich, ich glaube, Arrested Development und die Nürnberger Prozesse gucke ich mir in regelmäßigen Abständen im Loop nochmal an. So einmal pro Quartal. Ja, wirklich. Das sind die beiden Dinge. Vielleicht The Office, Arrested Development. Vielleicht die erste Staffel Sopranos noch. Ja, True Detective auch. Ja, auch nur die erste Staffel. Und die Nürnberger Prozesse. Einfach mal so im Loop. Ja, das stimmt schon. Die Creme der Creme der Naziführerschaft. Das macht so Spaß, das zu gucken. Man kennt sich ja auch selber in Situationen, wo man weiß, man hat Scheiße gebaut. Und dann kommt man auf eine Situation, wo man sich rausreden muss. Man weiß eigentlich, man hat nicht Recht gerade. Aber man ist halt in diesem Argumentiermodus, aber man hat eigentlich nicht Recht. Und bei denen ist es ähnlich. Es ist vor allem so, wenn sie behaupten, sie sind unschuldig, warum haben sie dann eine Zyankalikapsel im Mund? Ja, ja, genau. Ja, das hat doch damit die Bar. Das hat doch jeder von uns. Das hat doch damit überhaupt nichts zu tun. Das ist so ein Nazi-Ding. Das ist so ein Nazi-Ding. Hey, das haben wir alle. Wir finden das gut. Das ist auch so wie die Swastika. Das haben wir irgendwo ausgegraben. Das ist völliger Quatsch. Völliger Quatsch. Da muss alles übersetzt werden. Nonsense. Totally nonsense. No, no, I didn't do it. No, I didn't do it. Und ohne Scheiss, ich finde, ich glaube, ich habe ein kleines Rätsel gelöst, warum deutsche Dialoge oft scheiss klingen im Vergleich zu englischen Dialogen.
Zum Beispiel oft fällt es auch, wenn Kinder im Vergleich zu englischen Dialogen.
Z.B. oft fällt es auch, wenn Kinder sprechen oder Jugendliche in deutschen Filmen, finde ich, wirkt das oft nicht richtig,
weil Jugendliche so nicht sprechen.
Es fällt mir besonders in Deutschland auf.
Klar kann man sagen, die Autoren sind einfach schlechter,
aber ich glaube auch, dass es schwieriger ist,
deutsche Jugendsprache zu nailen,
weil ich glaube, die verändert sich wirklich drastischer
als die englische Sprache. Schneller als die amerikanische? Ja, ich glaube schon, weil ich glaube, die englische Sprache, die ist nicht so ganz so, also wenn man sich anguckt, wie damals englisch gesprochen wurde, zu Nürnberger Prozesszeiten und wie heute englisch gesprochen wurde, es klingt in etwa gleich. Also manche Wörter sind anders, manche Wörter kommen dazu, aber so der
Redefluss, auch wenn man sich englische
Nachrichtensprecher anguckt, irgendwie
das klingt alles sehr ähnlich, englische Reden,
aber Deutsch klang damals
ganz anders. Bei Nürnberger Prozessen,
die haben ganz, ganz anders geredet,
auch viel lauter. Nein, das
habe ich nicht! So haben die gesprochen.
Warum?
Also die reden anders.
Ich finde, Deutsch hat sich da ganz gewandelt.
Ja, ich überlege gerade, ob vielleicht auch der Unterschied zwischen Nomadasprache und Jugendsprache im Deutschen grösser ist als im Englischen,
aber man kennt sich wahrscheinlich einfach nicht so gut aus, wenn man die Sprache nicht so gut spricht.
Also das ist vielleicht so ein bisschen der Kern.
Dass bei jedem unserer Bits am Ende steht, dass wir eigentlich keine Ahnung haben, ist so bezeichnend.
Ja, das ist schade. Es ist einfach schade. Es ist wirklich schade. Hast du eine coole Doku gesehen? Eine coole Doku? Ich versuche mich gerade so ein bisschen in die ich versuche mich gerade so ein bisschen in die englischen Könige im Mittelalter. Ja, komm, ich höre doch euer Augen rollen bis hierher. Und so ein bisschen Edward der Zweite, Edward der Dritte, bis zu Richard the Second. Einfach, es ist, ja, ja, keine Ahnung. Und da gibt es dann so uncoole Dokus, wo die BBC sich Mühe gegeben hat, das möglichst cool zu machen. Und dann sieht alles so aus wie Game of of Thrones und so und dann gibt es so einen coolen, lässigen Typen, der dann durch die Show führt und du denkst dir einerseits, ja, das ist schon unterhaltsam, aber mir bleibt ja auch nach, ich weiß es auch nicht so, dass ich keine ich bin verloren gerade, ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht wohin. Aber mir gefallen diese Dokus ganz gut, also vor allem, weil die wechseln zwischen wir haben versucht, einen Mittelalterfilm zu drehen und wir haben versucht, eine Doku zu machen. Aber zwischendurch kommen dann halt, also entweder gibt es animierte Strecken, so grafisch gebaute Strecken irgendwie, wenn man dann irgendwie eine Stadt zeigt von oben, wie sie sich gewandelt hat und so, ist ja viel so Grafikdesign. Und dann manchmal kommen so Live-Roleplay-Sachen, wo dann auch wirklich Schauspieler sich die Sachen angezogen haben. Die sind immer grottenschlecht, die Schauspieler.
Also wirklich, glaube ich so, sobald du die Schauspielschule beendet hast,
sagst du, wenn du gut bist,
gehst du irgendwie
ans Theater, und wenn du schlecht bist,
gehst du zu diesen Re-Enactment-Sachen
von geschichtlichen Sachen, und du spielst
Napoleons Adjutant, der dann
irgendwie einfach mit gestellstmöglicher
Sprache, weil so hat man früher gesprochen,
früher haben die Leute sehr künstlich gesprochen, und so, also wie heute schlechte Schauspieler sprechen, so sprachen damals alle. Die Regierinbeisung. Das ist einfach der historische Fakt. Geht noch ein bisschen schlechter. Das hat man rekonstruiert aus alten Manuskripten, wo dann hieß, Napoleons Aditant sprach sehr künstlich und hat mit langen, unnatürlichen Pausen Napoleon Folgendes gesagt. Also auch da wurde das schon versucht einzubauen. Dass man später versteht, wie man sagt, ist ja tatsächlich interessant, dass es schwer ist zu rekonstruieren, wie Leute früher gesprochen haben, was ja keine Aufzeichnungen gibt. Und dann gibt es immer so ein, zwei Historiker von Tausenden und Millionen Menschen, die Latein gesprochen haben, von denen gibt es zwei, die auch am Rande mal erwähnt haben, wie irgendwas ausgesprochen wird und was sich reimt und was irgendwie ein Wortspiel war.
Und auf den beiden Deppen basiert alles. Das ist genau wie in der heutigen Sprache, hättest du irgendwie zwei Leute, die dir sagen, ja damals haben alle so und so gesprochen.
Deswegen, ja, historisch akkurat ist immer schwierig.
Unser Lateinlehrer meinte mal, dass Caesar eigentlich Kaiser ausgesprochen wurde. Das war alles. Das war der Laut, das war dieses Singlesangel. Kaiser. Ja, okay. Aber danach hat er das nie wieder angesprochen. Er hat auch Latein genauso stümperhaft, wie es halt da steht, ausgesprochen. Ich hätte gerne das Club Sandwich, eine kleine Kohle und den Kaiser Salad,, bitte. Ja, gerne, natürlich. Kriegst dann einen Schlag ins Gesicht, glaube ich. Das ist das, was du dann bekommst. Ich habe Salat für mich entdeckt. Erstmal gesünder, Leute. Was heisst für dich Salat? Blattsalat, also diese grossen Blätter. Ja, Felsalat. Ah, nee. Nee, nee, nee. Ich habe gestern versucht, ein ... Default-Salat halt. Wie heißt das denn? Es gibt Kopf-Salat. Ja, das. Diese Kugeln. M&M's. Ja. Was meinst du? Nee, nee, das war es schon. Das war das Bit. Ich wollte sagen, dass ich gestern versucht habe, zu kochen. Und ich eigene Soße machen und ich dachte mir, Soße ist ja im Grunde sehr leicht. Du nimmst Milch, kochst die ein, so dass das Wasser raus ist, so dass sie nur noch eklig schleimig ist und dann tust du Gewürze rein. Und dann habe ich das gemacht und dann habe ich die Soße probiert und dachte mir, okay, das schmeckt jetzt einfach nur nach dem Gewürz. Und dann dachte ich mir, ja Moment, aber was ist denn Geschmack? Also was ist denn... Du hast die Grundsatz, du hast die richtigen Fragen gestellt. Also weil, es stimmt schon, du kannst nicht einfach, also zum Beispiel Huhn mit Huhngewürz schmeckt gut, aber du kannst jetzt nicht einfach nur Wasser mit Huhngewürz essen, also es schmeckt natürlich nach dem Gewürz, aber es braucht schon irgendwo eine Basis. Konsistenz,
auch ein, glaube ich, ein grosser, grosser
Bruch. Also zum Beispiel, warum,
also Gewürze an sich haben
ja zum Beispiel keine Kalorien oder extrem
wenige. So, das heißt,
warum isst man nicht einfach, zum Beispiel Pringles,
was viele Leute machen,
sie lecken von den Pringles
das Gewürz runter. Und legen die Pringles
dann wieder in die Dose.
Eigentlich müsste man das doch machen, weil eigentlich das ganze Fett ist ja in den Pringles.
Da ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen was außenrum, die schwitzen so ein bisschen.
Aber warum kann man nicht einfach direkt nur das Gewürz essen?
Warum kann man nicht einfach so Zimt oder Pringles Gewürz in eine Tüte holen und das direkt essen?
Ich glaube, weil der Geschmack dann doch da drin ist auch. Aber wo drin? Du leckst es ja nur ab. Die Pringles, in den Pringles, an sich. Aber muss das Gewürz durch so eine Art Pringles drauf? Fett ist ja auch ein Geschmacksträger. Ja. Aber ich frage mich, wo trägt es das hin? Wohin? Hey, leg es mal ab, Fett. Jetzt leg mal den Geschmack wieder hin. Das ist auch so ein Ding. Ich meine, warum klappt das nicht? Es ist ja so ein klassischer Diätansatz, Sachen zu kauen und dann auszuspucken. Warum macht man das nicht? Warum klappt das nicht? Weil der Geschmack ist ja nur da. Ich glaube, da setzen auch irgendwann Urinstinkte ein. Der Urinstinkt, der sagt, schluck das jetzt runter, kau drauf rum, kau drauf rum. So funktioniert dein Gehirn? Kau jetzt rum. Oh, jetzt, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, kau, k. Vor allem wie bei Katzen, guck ruckartig zum Fenster und unterbrich alles, was du gerade machst und lass es nach zwei Sekunden wieder komplett vergessen und mach genau das, was du vorher gemacht hast, dein Felsabermachen, Felsabermachen, Felsabermachen und guck zum Fenster. Vor allem dieses klassische Vogel landet auf Balkon und Katze schaut reflexartig an, macht dann aber nichts. Ne, genau. Also was läuft da, ist da evolutionär falsch gelaufen, dass die Katze ihre Beute sieht, aber sich denkt, weißt du was? Nope. Müder Instinkt. Ich sag, weggezüchteter, müder Instinkt. Der Instinkt ist nicht mehr, guck da hin, greif's an. Der Instinkt ist eher so, oh, cool. Also im Grunde, Faulheit siegt über Instinkt. Man kann ja der Katze sagen, also der Katze zusprechen, also der Katze gut zureden. Nein. Also was ist das Gegenteil von absprechen? Also ich spreche dir Kompetenz ab. Zugestehen. Zugestehen, ja. Man kann ja der Katze Leute, kommt in zwei Folgen nochmal, dann haben wir die Grundlagen. Man kann ja der Katze anleihen, man kann der Katze anleihen, dass sie instinktgesteuert ist. Aber in dem Fall, Instinkt, Töte Maus, Töte Vogel, ist einfach so, ne komm, heute nicht. Ich hab heute schon Katzenfood gegessen, ich mach das jetzt nicht. Whiskas. Ja. Ich hab mal die, ich glaub, ich hab mal eine Katze gesehen, wo ich mir 80% sicher war, dass das die Sheba-Katze war. Und ich wollte ein Foto machen. Die was? Die Sheba-Katze, die auf dem Cover von Sheba ist, auf den Packungen. Das ist ja diese Anthrazit-Dunkelgraue, ganz Weiche, die so sehr mit dem Hintergrund verschmilzt und sich denkt so, wo fängt die Katze auf? Wo ist der Hintergrund, also ganz schlecht gewählter Hintergrund, Neongrün war aus oder was, also kann ich nicht nachvollziehen. Und ich dachte mir, das ist die echte Schieberkatze. Es könnte sein, dass man die echte Schieberkatze gesehen hat, ohne es bemerkt zu haben. Das könnte wirklich sein, genau wie du dann vielleicht häufig das Baby gesehen hast, was auf den Zigarettenpackungen abschrecken soll, dass man raucht. Ist das der beste Icebreaker ever?
Hey, schau mal auf deine Zigaretten.
Ja, okay, da hat jemand Lungenkrebs.
Das ist ein fremdes, das ist mein Kind, ich bin verheiratet.
Dieser Typen, der da in seine Unterhose schaut, wo drüber steht,
Rauchen tötet die Potenz, das bin ich.
Rauchen schrumpft das Glied.
Ich rauche aber nicht, ich bin nur mal, also ich rauche.
Ich habe ein kleines Glied, aber ich rauche nicht.
Rauchen ist ziemlich cool, ich rauche auch ein bisschen, aber nicht so, dass... Verdammt nochmal. Ich habe jetzt gehört, dass man auch Pfeffermens rauchen kann. Also man kann auch uncool... Den kann man alles rauchen. Ja, man kann alles rauchen. Aber halt, das ist auch gesund wohl, weil dann kannst du gut... Der Hals fühlt sich dann gut an. Vor allem, also ich finde diese ganze Raucherkultur, also Rauchen ist ja sehr, kulturtheoretisch ein interessantes Phänomen, weil es war lange cool, dann war es uncool und jetzt nimmt so eine Wandlung an, auch durch dieses Vapen.
Ich bin jemandem entgegengelaufen, der hat gewapt und sein Vape-Rauch roch nach Zuckerwatte.
Also der hatte Geschmacksrichtung Zuckerwatte. Wie sind wir gekommen von dem Marlboro-Cowboy, der irgendwie Pferde einholt, zu Schlumpfgeschmack innerhalb von 20 Jahren? Ja, und vor allem, ich war neulich hier auf der Fenloer Straße in Köln-Erenfeld unterwegs, sehr hip im Stadtteil, und hier wird auch gewapet, was das Zeug hält. Und ich bin einfach hinter einem jungen Mann hinterher gelaufen, einfach so, er musste in die gleiche Richtung wie ich, bin hinter ihm her gelaufen und plötzlich fand ich mich in einer Nebelwelt wieder. Einfach, ich dachte mir, wo bin ich denn jetzt, in einem David-Lynch-Film gelandet oder so. Plötzlich war überall Rauch und ich konnte nicht anders als einfach husten. Weil einfach alles, es war plötzlich Nebel. Und wenn du halt auf so ein Handy guckst, so morgens und noch nicht so richtig in der Welt bist, es war schon heftig, weil da kommt ja auch viel Rauch raus. Aber ich finde es auch geil, manche Leute rauchen und der Vapor ist noch mit dem MacBook angeschlossen. Der wird noch so geladen und man zieht so. Ich denke mir, what? Das ist ein illegales Vapen. So, ich lade mir das gerade runter. Und gleich in seinen Augen entsteht diese Eieruhr von Windows. Was kann man gleich auch in Cursor durch seine Augen bewegen? Das fühlt sich richtig falsch an. Warum ist Rauchen cool? Weil es schädlich ist und weil es eigentlich nicht schmeckt? Naja, sogar im Jugendalter ist es ja schon so, ah, wer hält es aus oder wer muss nicht husten? Es ist ja schon, weil es eklig ist. Aber das erste Mal Rauchen ist ja immer ekelhaft. Und ich glaube, das ist schon so eine Mutprobe, so ein Gehörste zu denen, die sich's trauen. Du fühlst dich nachher schon ruhiger und entspannter, das Nikotin hat auf jeden Fall eine Wirkung. Ja, klar, aber da kannst du auch ein gutes Buch lesen. Spieser Podcast. Eure Eltern empfehlen das Podcast Sufo. Der dann nochmal uncoolste Podcast der Welt. Habt erst Sex nach der Ehe und trinkt und raucht nicht. Die Nazis haben schon ein gutes Deutsch gesprochen, oder? Und man kann ja auch ein Buch lesen zur Entspannung. Podcast-Ufo. Lass das Rauchen sein. Also ich glaube, Rauchen wird völlig zu Absurdum geführt, weil es schmeckt viel zu gut und es ist nicht mehr schädlich. Ich habe jetzt wirklich nochmal True Detective geschaut und ich finde Rauchen so cool. Ja. Weil du hast halt zum einen, das sind ein paar Geräusche, die ich liebe. Ich liebe zum Beispiel, wenn Leute auf dem Handy tippen,. Dieses wenn sie schreiben. Das finde ich ein superschönes Geräusch. Und ich finde toll, wenn man in Filmen so ein richtig toll aufgenommenes Rauchen hat. Wenn das so, wenn du quasi hörst, wie das sich entzündet. Ja, dieses Knistern. Ja, dieses Knistern so leicht. Ganz toll ist es in dem Original Verblendung-Film, wenn Lisbeth Salander raucht, klingt das mega. Da würde ich sofort anfangen zu rauchen. Und bei True Detective ist es auch so geil.
Ich konnte True Detective echt lange, es hat mir körperlich weh getan, weil er wirklich raucht und er zieht den Rauch ein und atmet den dann nochmal so ein.
Also dieses wirklich harte, auf Lunge gnadenlose Rauchen. Und dann spricht er, glaube ich, ich weiß nicht, ob es daran liegt, er war so automatisch und Southern Accent.
Er kommt ja auch, glaube ich, aus Texas im Moment.
Also, so cool. Es ist wirklich mega cool. Vor allem, du hast ja diese Figur, der du einfach ansiehst, dass sie einfach all in geht. Einfach so dieses, ich rauche nicht nur, mir ist es, ich mache wirklich bis ans Ende. Wo ich mir denke, der arme Matthew McConaughey, der hat einfach 30 Takes immer wieder wirklich eine Zigarette nach der anderen auf dem Gebrauch.
Der muss durch sein. Der braucht keine Maske, der sagt danach so, die Haare waren direkt lang und vergilbt.
Sofort, wieder drei Takes lang und vergilbt.
Aber das hat aber auch keine echten geraucht.
Und deswegen denke ich mir, das finde ich manchmal schon ziemlich cool.
Das ist auch, glaube ich, eine Mischung aus, man fühlt sich ein bisschen besser.
Du hast vor allem dieses ab und zu rausgehen, das ist wirklich ganz cool. Und Raucher sind automatisch Socializer, müssen die sein. Weil du halt immer diese unange... Also ich finde es geil, mit Rauchern abzuhängen, weil du hast wie so Werbepausen, wo man sich nochmal neu sammeln kann, was will ich gleich mit ihm besprechen, weil er ist gerade draußen an den Rauchen und hat immer so wirklich jede halbe Stunde, guck, da kommt er raus, seine Raucher und kommt dann wieder. Du hast also immer so eine Pause mit ihm, mit einem Raucher, Du kannst immer dann nochmal sammeln, was willst du mit ihm besprechen, und du kannst wie so eine kleine Show mit ihm abfahren. Top-Tipp für Nichtraucher, Toilette. Meine Werbepause ist die Toilette. Einfach mal schön alle 15 Minuten einfach kurz sagen, hey Leute, ich bin kurz raus. Es ist so gut, ne? Zack, mal kurz irgendwie nochmal ein paar Gags nachschlagen, irgendwie im Notizblock, einfach ein paar, okay, ein paar Themen. Ich bin viel zu lange immer auf einer Toilette. Es ist so eine coole Welt, so eine Parallelwelt. Draußen hörst du die wummernden Bässe, die schreienden Mädchen, die grölnden Jungs. Es gibt auch viele coole Filmszene auf Toiletten. Es ist immer so, du hast auf dem Dancefloor immer diese relativ langweiligen Montagen, so dieses Dancen und Krasse, und dann hast du so ein Strobolicht oder irgendwie sowas. Und dann hast du, also ich glaube, es gibt keine einzige Clubszene, die nicht nahtlos an eine Clubtoilettenszene anschließt. Weil, was sollst du machen, wir gehen in den Club rein und sind direkt wieder raus. Also das ist ja doof, du musst ja irgendwo, im Club kannst du nicht reden. Du musst kurz Urlaub haben vom Club. Ja, und dann bist du direkt in der Toilette oder hast du die und dann kannst du irgendwie so, die schminken sich dann nochmal alle. Das ist wie so ein Kurzurlaub, finde ich. Das ist halt so etwas ganz Erholsames. Ich glaube, man geht auch nur in Club, um du die ... Und dann kannst du irgendwie so ... Die schminken sich dann noch mal alle. Das ist wie so ein Kurzurlaub, finde ich.
Das ist halt so was ganz Erholsames.
Ich glaube, man geht auch nur in den Club, um auf die Club-Talette zu gehen.
Weil da ist so dieses, du kannst es, glaube ich, besser genießen, wenn du nicht direkt drin bist, sondern wenn du so von außen so ein bisschen.
Du bist kurz für dich, du kannst kurz durchatmen, du kannst kurz sagen, was, ich habe gerade zu Barbie-Girl getanzt, du kannst in dich gehen, hinterfragen, was du gerade gemacht hast, bist für dich alleine, auf dich gestellt. Und dann ist die Frage, also wie gehst du mit Toiletten um, öffentlichen Toiletten? Also jetzt ist die Frage, gut, Nummer eins oder Nummer zwei, führen wir uns mal da durch, da haben wir noch nie gesprochen, komm, wir gehen mal in die Abgründe. Ja. Öffentliche Telettenetten haben oft Probleme. Also erst mal ich setze mich hin auf die Toilette, dann mache ich zunächst nehme ich das Klopapier und mache dann drei, zwei. Also für die längliche Seite habe ich drei Klopapierblätter, unten zwei, auf der anderen Seite wieder drei. Das habe ich noch nie gemacht. Nein? Bei mir gibt es einmal den gegen den Uhrzeigersinn, den doppelten gegen den Uhrzeigersinn. Du machst sauber. Ja, ja. Ich lasse dich drauf liegen und setze mich dann auf die Toilette. Nee, das meine ich nicht. Nein? Nee. Das finde ich interessant. Es kommt auch auf die Toilette an. Es bringt halt auch nichts. Weil sobald du dich draufsetzt, verrutscht auch alles und dann fällt das halt so rein, also es passt alles nicht so richtig. Und dann, wie viele Lagen nimmst du, weil es ist ja immer zu dünn. Eine ganze Menge, 20 würde ich sagen. Ich finde aber, das Allerwichtigste bei öffentlichen Toiletten ist, mir geht es gar nicht um Hygiene, mir geht es gar nicht um Klopapier, mir geht es darum, ob Haken sind, dass man seine Sachen aufhängen kann. Ich nehme lieber ein dreckiges Klo mit Haken als ein sauberes ohne Haken.
Ich finde, das ist ein Commitment dabei.
Haken ist ein Commitment.
Ich habe immer meinen Rucksack dabei, ich habe immer eine Jacke dabei.
Aber dann sagst du, du willst jetzt längere Zeit verbringen.
Naja, wenn ich einen Rucksack dabei habe oder eine Jacke dabei habe.
Stimmt, den kannst du nicht aufbehalten.
Und deswegen ist es immer so,
dann hast du teilweise diese zerbrechlichen Haken,
wo ich nicht weiss, kann ich da jetzt meinen Rucksack dranhängen, brich das ab, was mit der Jacke, die ist auch gar nicht schwer geworden, es regelt draußen, jetzt ein bisschen vollgesaugt. Und immer der Doublecheck, ob du wirklich abgeschlossen hast, immer der Doublecheck. Immer der Doublecheck, immer nochmal zweimal dagegen treten, laut schreien. Ich bin die Tränen besetzt! Ja. Ja. Das stimmt schon. Toiletten. Ich lieb. Vor allem, und du weißt genau, ich komm noch einmal wieder heute Abend, ich komm noch einmal wieder auf die Lette und dann kann ich gehen. Ich weiß, ich bin wirklich so unsozial, dass ich wirklich so, ich liebe das zu gehen. Ja. Sobald es sozial akzeptiert ist, zu gehen, der Moment, wo man rausgeht aus dem Club, die frische Nachtluft einatmet und dann nach Hause kann. Alle lassen einen in Ruhe, man muss noch ein paar Leuten sagen, ich muss jetzt nach Hause, Leute fragen, bleib doch ein bisschen, wo man denkt, du willst mit jemandem abhängen, der offensichtlich nach Hause will, warum fragst du mich jetzt noch mal, man hat mit allen gesprochen, alle haben sozial akzeptiert, dass du jetzt nach Hause gehen kannst, besser Moment. Ja, ich glaube, das ist auch der einzige Reiz
für mich an solchen Partys, der Thrill,
dass jetzt gehe ich nach Hause.
Und vor allem, bei mir war es letztens so,
ich war wirklich auf eine Party eingeladen und ich dachte, da gäbe es was
zu essen und deswegen habe ich davon nicht
gegessen und dann komme ich da an und merke,
es gibt nichts zu essen und ich hatte Hunger
und dann dachte ich mir wirklich,
zehn Minuten, nachdem ich gekommen bin, dachte ich, hey Leute,
ich hole mir kurz was zu essen und komme dann wieder, war draußen und dachte mir, ich gehe noch aus, ich kann jetzt gehen. Du bist schon draußen. Und ich bin schon draußen und ich habe jetzt eine Entschuldigung für eine Stunde, also ich gehe irgendwie, hole mir einen Döner oder sowas und ich kann einfach gehen und bin einfach nicht mehr noch gekommen. Bei mir ist es, wenn ich in den Klub gehe, zwei Prozent Spaß, drei Prozent, komm, wir machen das einfach ironisch, ich nehm eine Persona an, immer diese komische Comedy-Bit, so Rab-in-Gefahr-Ideen, die man hat, wie man den Abend verbringen könnte. Und 95 Prozent Weiber. Und 95 Prozent Titten, Baller, Bum, Bum. Nee, und 95 Prozent Ausreden überlegen, um jetzt maximal früh wieder nach Hause gehen zu können. Was ist der früheste Moment, an dem man gehen kann? Ich glaube, zehn Minuten ist wirklich zu früh. Das war mal so geil, da bin ich reingegangen, direkt irgendwie, einmal kam ein Kumpel von mir nicht rein, mega! Ah, yes! Einmal kam, einmal wurde eine Freundin von mir direkt das Portemonnaie geklaut, wo ich mir denke, yes! Und das waren die besten Ausgaben. Wirklich, der schönste Satz, den es, also vielleicht, der zweitschöne Satz ist, ihr Kind wurde wiedergefunden, das ist okay, guter Satz, guter Satz, hört man gerne, aber der schönste Satz, und der ist in vielen Kontexten anwendbar, und deswegen liebe ich ihn so, der schönste Satz ist, ja, das lohnt jetzt auch nicht mehr. Yes, es lohnt sich nicht mehr. Vor allem es heißt, gefasste Pläne werden auch, also dieses, ja wir wollen am Wochenende in die Berge fahren und dann, oh nein, am Samstag regnet es, wollen wir am Sonntag noch fahren, ja das lohnt sich jetzt auch nicht mehr. Machen wir weiterhin nichts. Oder einfach so, du kommst in den Club nicht rein, sollen wir jetzt nochmal auf die andere Startseite fahren, um in den anderen Club zu gehen? Ja, das lohnt sich jetzt auch nicht mehr. Bist du häufig der, dass er das sagt? Nein, das darf man nicht. Eben nicht, weil du willst ja auch nicht als der wirken, der unbedingt will, aber wenn es jemand anders sagt, das ist einfach so, die Götter reissen den Himmel auf und der Engelschor erschallt zu den Worten, ja, das lohnt sich jetzt auch nicht mehr. Vor allem, da gab es so eine Clubsituation, ich weiß das Jahr nicht mehr im Club, aber da habe ich dann zu mich mal... Ich glaube, die heißen jetzt wieder Disco. Ja, kann gut sein. Da habe ich mich aufgewacht, zu einer Begleitung zu sagen, ja, ich habe gar nicht richtig Bock, weil mir habe ich ausgewacht, wie eigentlich geht es mir dann immer darum, wann ich wieder gehen kann, und sie so, ja, ich auch, bei mir ist es genauso. Und dann haben wir den anderen Kumpel, der dabei war, der hatte auch keine Lust. Und dann sag ich mir auch so, was ist denn eigentlich, hat irgendwer Lust auf Club? Das ist eine interessante Frage. Ich glaube, hat irgendwer der DJ Bock? Hat er Bock auf die Songs, die er gerade spielt? Hat die Bartenderin, niemand hat gerade Lust, hier zu sein. Sorry, ganz kurz, einmal Don't Drink and Drive gilt weiterhin, aber hat hier irgendjemand wirklich Bock zu sein?
Können alle Singles kurz einfach aufzeigen und dann sich irgendwie...
Holt euch Tinder, straight, holt euch Tinder, done. Und der Rest, eigentlich können wir...
Wollen wir aufhören? Hat jemand Bock?
Ihr kriegt, er hätte dann in einer Stunde noch Coupons bekommen für diesen Burgerladen, der neu aufgemacht hat, gebe ich euch jetzt.
Und ansonsten spiele ich euch raus zu I'm a Sunny Girl. I'm a Barbie Girl. Barbie Girl? Es braucht nicht viel, um Details zu sein. I'm a Barbie Girl! I'm a Barbie Girl! I'm in Plastic! Ein weiterer Rohrwurm. Furchtbarer Song. Ja, aber das ist wirklich so Clublife. Aber jetzt, vielleicht war das das most relatable Bit, was wir jemals gemacht haben, vielleicht hat es niemand verstanden, weil es alle immer anders sehen. Aber ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich ein Ding. Ich glaube, solle Leute reagieren ... Ich glaube, Clubs sind einfach dazu da, um ... für den nächsten Mating-Ritual. Gibt's denn Statistiken darüber, ob mehr oder weniger Leute in Clubs gehen heutzutage oder so? Gibt es da Statistiken?
Nee, ich glaube, das wird, glaube ich, nicht untersucht. Es wird untersucht, ob mehr Leute rauchen, ob mehr Leute Drogen nehmen, aber so Clubs, es wird nicht untersucht, was einem weh tut, glaube ich. Das ist ein echt interessanter Satz. Ein sehr falscher Satz. Oder nichts, was Geld macht. Oh. Oh, ne ich glaube, es gehen ähnlich viel in Clubs, weil es ist halt so, ich glaube, man macht es ja aber lustig auf dem Discovery Channel, wenn man mal Tiere sieht, die tanzen oder irgendwie ihr Federkleid ausfahren bei so einem Brunfttanz, aber ich glaube, nichts anderes machen Menschen. Man tanzt, um den Partner zu finden, mit dem man dann den Geschlechtsakt vollzieht oder halt dann zusammenkommt auf lange Zeit.
Ich habe gestern 200 Gramm Penne weggeworfen,
weil die Soße einfach scheiße war.
Weil es nicht funktioniert hat.
Und ich dachte, für einen kurzen Moment
soll ich die jetzt abwaschen
und die Penne so essen.
Wie so ein
Mülleimer.
Also wirklich wie so ein, einfach Klappe auf, rein damit, keine Ansprüche, keine Erwartungen.
Ich habe die weggeworfen.
Lässt du im Restaurant Dinge zurückgeben?
Nein, nie, oder?
Würde ich niemals machen.
Vor allem, ich denke mir doch, also erstmal habe ich eh schon kein Vertrauensverhältnis zu den Leuten im Restaurant. Ich will sehen, wie man mein Essen macht. Deswegen finde ich Dönerladen auch eigentlich das Beste. Also McDonalds, das ist alles immer so, was habt ihr mit meinem Burger gemacht, wo kommt der her? Die Schwelle zu ins Essen spucken ist so niedrig. Ja. Für jeden. Du musst so wenig Aufwand betreiben, um jemandem das wirklich alles zu versauen gerade. Und neulich war ein Haar in meinem Essen. Ich fuhr Dora, da habe ich einfach so ein großes Haar ausgefischt. Und danach habe ich einfach weiter gegessen, weil ich dachte, was soll ich jetzt tun? Ist es nicht essen? Ja, und ein Haar ist jetzt, also ist das jetzt super unhygienisch ein Haar? Ja, ich dachte mir, das Haar war halt auf dem Kopf, also ein Stück Hand wäre schlimmer. Ja, aber am Kopf ist nichts. Selten, dass man mal mit dem Kopf irgendwie wo ist.
Naja, wenn in einem niedrigen Raum.
Bitte,
nicht vorher im niedrigen Raum.
Aber wenn so ein Stück Hand oder so ein Stück
Fingernagel, das wäre widerlich. Mir fehlt
einfach Ekel. Ich glaube, also vielleicht bin ich
evolutionär weiter als ihr,
weil vielleicht evolutioniert
sich Ekel irgendwie raus aus dem Menschen.
Vielleicht bin ich eine Mutation, die einfach keinen Ekel
hat. Und wenn das gut läuft, dann
haben irgendwie in der Zukunft alle keinen Ekel.
Aber muss ich sagen Mutation, die einfach keinen Ekel hat. Und wenn das gut läuft, dann haben irgendwie in der Zukunft alle keinen Ekel. Man muss ja manchmal so als Evolution mal was raushauen und einfach sagen, so pass auf, du kriegst mal Flügel, wir gucken mal, ob es läuft. Und wenn es läuft, dann haben es alle. Wo sind die Menschen mit Flügeln? Ja, irgendwo in, ich weiß nicht. In Angl. In anderen fremden Ländern. In den Angl. Im Allgäu. Was ist das? Und mir fehlt auch einfach Ekel, deswegen kann ich da, ich finde so ein Haar im Essen auch nicht schlimm. Fingernagel? Was fändst du schlimm? Man würde es Essen zurückgeben lassen. Also wenn man drüber nachdenkt, auch nicht, aber das war wahrscheinlich schon auf dem ersten Moment. Ich würde dann halt so in einem Radius von zwei Zentimeter, so einen guten Esslöffel würde ich um den Fingernagel rum kontaminieren und dann weiter essen. Isst du erst das Gute auf dem Teller oder erst das Perfekte? Also ich lasse immer, meistens esse ich immer den, erst mal esse ich den Salat weg und so, alles was nicht so geil ist und dann lasse ich mir das Steak mal zum Ende auf. Ja, erst das Schlechte, von Schlechtem zu gut. Erst das Schlechte, ne, und dann zum Guten. Damit das Gute kalt ist. Weil kalt ist besser als warm. Und damit hätten wir das auch geklärt.
Ja, schön.
Stefan Tietze, vielen Dank, dass du diese Woche wieder Zeit genommen hast.
Wir gucken mal, wann wir die große, gute Abed Originals,
sag ich mal, die gute All-Star-Talkrunde starten.
Aber das wird vielleicht bald kommen, aber wie ihr uns kennt, wahrscheinlich nicht vor 1.40. Mal gucken, ansonsten auch vielen Dank natürlich wieder an den User, der uns das Intro für diese Woche gegeben hat. Lars! Vielen Dank, Lars! Vielen Dank, Lars! Nicht Lars, oder? Ich weiß es nicht, wer da ... Mann, auch mal.
Chris, vielen Dank, Chris.
Vielen Dank an Chris für dieses Fantasen-Fan-Tag.
Das ist mir eine gute Idee, dass du immer den Namen in den Dateinamen schreibst.
Ja.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Cool.
Ja, kommt gut durch die Woche.
Haut rein.
Anlagetipp Gold dieses Mal.
Anlagetipp Gold.
Macht's gut.
Alles klar.
Ciao, macht's gut.
Wir wissen wie ein Magazin, wo hinten so eine Finanzsection noch ist.
Und noch eine Werbung von irgendwie Rolex.
Tschau. Und wir eben ab, tschau.